In this course, you'll learn to use Git, which is a version control system, and
GitHub, a code sharing and collaboration platform.
You'll need to use a Unix-style command line, so if you haven't used that
before, then check out one of the tutorials in the instructor's notes.
You'll also be looking at some code in this course, so experience reading and
writing code will be useful, but
it doesn't matter which particular programming languages you know.
To give you a better sense of what you'll learn if
you stick with us through this course, here's the rough breakdown.
We'll have three lessons.
In this first lesson, we'll focus on how version control can be useful and
what different forms it might take.
You'll also install Git and start using it to explore some existing code.
Then, in lesson two, you'll learn more about Git and start using it on your own.
Finally, in lesson three, you'll get some practice sharing code and
collaborating with others using GitHub.